حول همم تفاصيلها وتطور الموقف هناك ينضم
الينا
مجدداح حافظ كيف يتطور الموقف اذا
[موسيقى]
نعم سفيان في الحقيقه ثمه بعد المواجهات
المتفرقه التي ما زالت جاريه في بعض
الانهج القريبه هنا من ساحه الجمهوريه
خصوصا في افنيبل في اتجاهه
لبستيه ثمه مواجهات بين عدد من الشبان
والمحتاجين وقوات الشرطه والامن التي
تحاول السيطره عليهم نشتم رائحه الغاز
المسير للدموع قويه هنا في صحتها
الجمهوريه جرى هذه الاشتباكات التي تبعد
عشرات الامطار من هذا المكان حيث اقف همم
الان نشاهد هناك الدخان ما زال يرتفع
واعمده الدخان جراء حرقي عدد من المعدات
وايضا تحشيم همم عدد من الواجهات وغيرها
نشاهد ايضا اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من
النيران والسنه اللهب اشعلها
متظاهرون همم هنا قرب ساحتي لافا في وسط
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس للتعبير عن غضبهم
بعد هذا الهجوم الذي يصفونه بالعنصري
وايضا بالارهابي في الدوافع السياسيه كما
يقول المسؤولون الاكراد والمتظاهرون
الاكراد هنا نشاهد النيران ما زالت تشتعل
هذه النيران اضرمها المحتاجون باحتجاجا
على ما يعتبرونه تقصيرا من السلطات
الفرنسيه في حمايتهم لاسامه وان المسؤولين
الاكراد يقولون ان همم انهم سبق ان طالب
من السلطات الفرنسيه بالتعزيز حمايتي
مقاهرهم وبتجديد حمايه الامنيه على
الجاريه الكرديه خصوصا وان هذه همم هذه
الفتره من العام تتزام مع مروري نحو عشر
سنوات عن هجوم مماثل لهذا الهجوم في
الحقيقه راح هذا حياته ثلاثه
اكراد انا ذاكر وتمت محاولات من قبل
السلطات للتهدي نوعا ما بلغنا بان همم
محافظ شرطه باريس كان قد استقبل صباح
اليوم في حدود العاشره صباحا بتوقيت
المحلي عددا من ممثلي الجاليه الكرديه لكن
ذلك على ما يبدو الى حد اللحظه لم يكن
كفيلا بتهدئه الاوضاع وتهدئه الغضب الذي
نراه في الاعين هنا في ساحه الجمهوريه
وايضا نشاهده في هذه الاشتباكات
والمواجهات المتواصله بين الشرطه
والمحتاجين معلومه اخرى بلغتنا منذ قليل
لان وزير العدل له همم
سوف يستقبل ممثلين عن الجاليه الكرديه في
حدود الساعه الرابعه مساء بتوقيت باريس
وحتى القضاء مع هذه المساله وحتى التعامل
الاعلامي مع
ده الهجوم ال اا متظاهرون هنا يقولون ان
هذا الهجوم تم التعامل معه بطريقه مختلفه
نسبيا عامه كان يقع في اوقات اخرى عندما
يكون المستهدفون ليسوا من الجاليات
المهاجره
وغيرها في الحقيقه رائحه الغاز هنا قويه
في ساحه الجمهوريه ونشاهد ان عددا من
متظاهرين بسبب مغادره الساحه والتوجه نحو
الشوارع الفرعيه هذا ياتي بعد همم طلب من
المنظمين في اكثر من مناسبه من من
المتظاهرين هنا في الساحه باخلاء الساحه
والمغادره يقولون ان رسالتهم واضحه وانهم
ارسلوا الرسائل اللازمه ويريدون ان او
بانفسهم عن الاشتباكات الجاريه التي
يعتبرون انها لا تمث فعلا هم يريدون ارسال
رساله السلام يريدون القول وامامه العالم
انهم ضحايا الارهاب كما يقولون وضحايا
العنصريه هنا في فرنسا فرنسا التي يقولون
انهم جاؤوا اليها للاحتماء همم بها همم
كما يقول المسؤولون الاكراد هنا لكن في
اكثر من مناسبه تتم مهاجمتهم على حد
تعبيرهم في الحقيقه رائحه الغاز المسير
للدموع قويه هنا في صحه الجمهوريه جراء
هذه الاشتباكات التي ما زالت الجاريه ونرى
اعمده الدخان كثيفه تتصاعد في ساحه
الجمهوريه
في اتجاه ساحه لبستيه تم مواجهات ما زالت
جاريه ونور نرى في الصوره بان الدخان يعم
المكان في الحقيقه وهذه الصوره تعبر عن
الاوضاع الان في ساحه لبستين وفي ساحه
الجمهوريه ساحه البريني في اتجاه طريق
الساحه
وعن الغضب العالم والكبير في الاوساط
الكرديه لكن ليس فقط لاوساط الكرديه لدى
المهاجرين عموما هنا في فرنسا الذين
يعتبرون انفسهم اليوم باتوا حطب الخطاب
الشعبي اليمني المتشدد والمترف همم الذي
سار يتحدث دون حسيب رقيب على حد تعبيره
سواء في بعض وسائل الاعلام او على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي السيارات التونسيه
هيساريه همم التي ادانت بشده هذا الهجوم
اعتبرت ان نعم